I'll now explain to you why from 2000 to
2005 we had very low defaults on
mortgages let's say that let's say that
I you know I buy a house for a million
dollars I buy a million dollar house so
let's say the bank gives me a million
dollars and then I'm willing to pay a
percentage on it so this is from the
bank this is me and I use that to buy a
house I don't know if these diagrams
help you but you get the general idea
and the bank does that and let's say I
don't know a year later I lose my job I
just can't pay this mortgage anymore so
I have a couple of options I can either
sell the house sell house and pay off
the debt or or I guess I could just you
know tell the bank well I can't do
anything and I'm gonna foreclose and
that would ruin my credit it would hurt
my credit and I would lose all my down
payment so what are the circumstances
that I can sell the house well if I
borrowed a million dollars as long as
and let's say I did put no money down
just for simplicity if I can sell the
house for 1.1 million dollars well I
would do it right listen let me sell for
1.1 million if I sell for 1.1 million I
pay the bank let me switch colors I pay
the bank a million pay 1 million and I
net a hundred thousand dollars and
everyone's happy the bank got their
money back so they didn't lose many
money on the transaction I made $100,000
and so the whole reason why this worked
out even though maybe I was a credit
risk is because the housing prices went
up so when you have rising housing
prices you'll have you'll practically
the banks will not lose money lending
you lending you because if you can't pay
you just give back the house the bank
can sell or you won't even give back the
house you'll sell the house and you'll
pay it off even though you can't pay the
mortgage anymore
the only situation where I would
foreclose is if the market price of the
house goes less than my loan and that's
actually a situation that we're facing
now so if let's say that I can only sell
this house for $900,000 well then I'm
just gonna give the keys back to give
the keys back to the bank that's
actually called jingle mail because you
just mailed the keys back and then the
bank sells the house for 900,000 and
then they would take a loss so when
housing prices go down this is
this is the situate you that's the only
situation where really you should have
foreclosure but when housing prices go
up
the person who borrowed it is just going
to sell the house and pay off the loan
and they are actually probably gonna
make some money so there was every
incentive to buy a house so let's think
about this whole dynamic over the last
few for the last several videos that
we've been building so we said we said
from 2000 to 2004 housing prices went up
now let me do it like this let me let me
change it a little bit so we know that
from so this is all going to be we could
even say from 2000 to 2006 so we know
that housing prices went up housing
prices up and why did why did housing
prices go up well we saw the data it
wasn't because people were earning more
it wasn't because the unemployment rate
went down it wasn't because the
population increased it wasn't because
the supply of houses were limited we
disproved all of that we realized it was
just because financing got easier the
standards for getting a loan went lower
and lower financing it got easier and
easier and because housing prices went
up what did what did that cause what we
just said when housing prices go up
default rates go down default rates go
down
alright you could give a loan to someone
who's a complete deadbeat but they as
long as housing prices go up and if they
lose their job they can still sell that
house and pay you back the loan so
housing prices going up make sure
there's no foreclosures so defaults go
down so then the perceived risk goes
down of lending the perceived let me
write that perceived what's happening
perceived lending risk lending risk goes
down
so that makes more people willing to
lend more people willing to lend and you
know corollary of more people willing to
lend is that the actual standards go
down and that's financing easier we
could actually write that standards go
down standards go down so you had this
whole I mean I guess you could argue
whether this is a negative or a positive
cycle but you had this whole cycle
occurring oh it from the late 90s but
especially it got it really got a lot of
momentum and at around 2001 2002 2003
that financing got easier despite the
fact that people were earning less
population wasn't increasing that fast
that there were all of these new houses
and that caused housing prices to go up
housing prices went up then we had a lot
fewer people defaulting on their loans
and no one would default on their loans
if they can sell it for more than the
loan then people then a lot more people
said well these are super safe and so
you know the the ratings agency Standard
& Poor's and Moody's were willing to
give triple-a ratings to more and more
what I would argue are risky loans so
the perceived lending risk went down
then more and more people like this
asset classes where they said wow this
is great I can get a better return than
I can get in a bank or in Treasuries or
in a whole set of securities even though
these are very low risk or perceived low
risk so I want to funnel more and more
money in here and so the mortgage
brokers and the investment banks is said
great you know the only way we can get
more volume to satisfy all these people
who want to lend money the only way we
can find more people to lend money to is
by lowering the standards and this cycle
went round and round and round and it
really started because this whole
process of being able to take a bunch of
people's mortgages together package them
up and then you know turned them into
securities and then sell them to a bunch
of investors this was a quote unquote
innovation in the mid 90s or early 90s I
forgot exactly when and it and it really
started to take steam in in the early
part of this decade so that's
essentially why housing prices went up
and and why kind of all of the silliness
happened and in the next video I'll talk
a little bit more about maybe who's what
whose what some of these investors were
and I'll tell you what a a common a
hedge fund technique and it's I think
it's very important not to group all
hedge funds together there are some good
ones but what a common hedge fund
technique was to take advantage of this
virtuous cycle to make the hedge fund
founders very wealthy I'll see you soon